foreign
hello everyone and uh thank you miles
for allowing us to host a PM connect uh
event here today
um you'd have seen I came here uh not so
long ago to see your massive investment
in in the new monster lines here
um and both for pm and I both respect
and love the Coca-Cola company for what
it does and how it operates
um across the globe but especially here
and actually you've kind of one of the
reasons why the Prime Minister has spent
so much time making sure that we get our
negotiations on the protocol right
because you operate across all of
Ireland and we needed to make sure that
any new relationship both looked after
those looked after both those markets
but protected uh Northern Ireland's
place in our union now we think we've
managed to do that but to explain it
more I'd like to hand you over to the
prime minister
foreign
everybody thanks Chris thanks miles for
having us and just before we get going I
know like me all of you will be thinking
of John Caldwell and his family and it's
absolutely appalling and shocking attack
and I know we're all thinking of them
and praying hard for a strong recovery
for John but it's a reminder actually
that there are some in our society that
want to take us back to the past and I
know that none of us want to see that
happen we want to look forward and
actually that's what I saw when Chris
and I were here in one of my previous
visits at the end of last year and we
went to Harland and wolf and saw all the
incredible investment that's going in
the new Royal Navy contracts the jobs
that are being created it was an
enormous sign of Promise about what was
possible and again miles is doing it
right here with the investment that's
happening in this Factory and facility
and jobs that are being created it's a
sign of what is possible and that's the
potential that I am so Keen to realize
for the people of Northern Ireland but I
also know
that things are not working as they
should be and the protocol that was
negotiated as it was being implemented
was causing real challenges for people
for families for businesses here in
Northern Ireland and in too many ways it
just didn't feel right it didn't feel
right it didn't feel that the balance of
the Belfast Good Friday agreement that
was so painstakingly negotiated and
settled for almost a quarter of a
century that balance had been disrupted
and that's why I've spent a lot of time
together with Chris and others working
really hard to try and find a resolution
on that thorny issue and I'm really
pleased in fact I'm over the moon that
yesterday we managed to have a decisive
breakthrough with our negotiations with
the EU reached agreement the New Windsor
framework that I think is an
extraordinary positive step for Northern
Ireland and it represents as the
European Union president herself said a
historic moment for us to move forward
and resolve some of the difficulties of
the past well what does it achieve well
in a nutshell does three things the
first is it ensures that Goods can flow
freely across our United Kingdom
internal market so that if someone is
sending something from Great Britain to
Northern Ireland we've managed to create
something called a Green Lane so it can
just move very smoothly without tons of
Customs paperwork or hassle or checks
we've made sure that that that process
feels to anybody as if they're in the
same country because they are in the
same country and it didn't feel like
that before and that was disrupting
businesses and supply lines so that bit
has been fixed which is brilliant but
also it's not just businesses that are
sending things up and uh or back and
forth across also people someone sending
their granddaughter a birthday present
in a parcel someone doing online
shopping all of that was also about to
need tons of Customs Hassle and that
would have been ridiculous right so
we've managed to fix all of that as well
so things can just move freely and
smoothly between Great Britain and
Northern Ireland and that's what the
Green Lane is about but it's also about
making sure that the same goods are they
expect that you get all the same
benefits of being part of that country
wherever you live and in too many ways
that didn't feel didn't feel like it was
working right when you went to the
garden center and you couldn't get the
same oak trees I remember famously of
the Jubilee when we celebrated her late
Majesty's Jubilee there were these
Jubilee Oaks they weren't available in
Northern Ireland's garden centers seed
potatoes such an important part of
Northern Ireland's Horticultural
industry not available
you think about medicines we have the
situation where it was going to be the
case that the UK might license a really
impressive new drug to help treat cancer
and it won't be available for patients
here in Northern Ireland when I was
Chancellor I was cutting taxes in fact I
cut taxes on beer Duty in pubs which we
can do once we left the EU we could say
actually we're going to have one tax for
beer that you buy elsewhere but when
you're in the pub you want to have a
lower tax on beer and we could do that
and I announced it and it's going to
happen in the rest of the UK this summer
but it wasn't able to happen in Northern
Ireland and that didn't seem right at
all when you take your pet on holiday
it's another example someone coming to
take their pet on holiday had to get a
rabies
job they had to get a certificate from
their vet they'd get tapeworm treatment
and that all is clearly ridiculous so
those were all the ways in which I felt
Hang on we're not part of the same
country well we've resolved all of those
issues thanks to the work we've done and
and crucially I talked about product
availability the hassle of getting a
supermarket Lorry from Great Britain to
Northern Ireland with enormous hundreds
of certificates
hundreds of tons of bureaucracy to get
through it and worse
what was available in Great Britain on
the shelves in the supermarkets which I
know is a bit challenging at the moment
but it's getting better but more
generally was not available in the
shelves in Northern Ireland but that
wasn't right and we've resolved all
those issues so that there's going to be
the same things in both places which is
as it should be and that brings me on to
the third thing
and the third thing is really important
it's about sovereignty it's about all of
you it's about making sure you the
people of Northern Ireland and your
elected representatives are in control
and that you have a say in what happens
to you and I think for too many people
it felt like hang on we accept that we
have access to the EU market and that's
a good thing and we accept that we don't
want to have a border on the island of
Ireland a hard border we accept that and
that's a good thing and because of that
we recognize that there is some role for
EU law but we need to have a say on that
can't just ignore us when it comes to
that and that was what was missing and
we did something really special
yesterday we created this new thing
called the storm won't break which means
that your assembly
is going to be able to have a look at
any of the new EU laws that come down
the pipe and say hang on if there's
something that's really serious that we
think is going to have a really big
impact and we can't find any way to
resolve it then we have the ability to
say no that we can block it and at which
point the UK government will have a veto
on that new rule and that puts you in
the driving seat so that is a really
powerful new mechanism that we've
created it puts democracy and
sovereignty back in Northern Ireland
where it belongs and I think it's a
really powerful commitment to all of you
that the concerns that I've heard that
Chris has heard over weeks months and
years have been listened to taken
seriously and now acted on and I'm here
to answer your questions I'm here to
listen to you as I have been over the
past months that I've had this job about
what we can do to make your lives better
because that's ultimately what I'm here
for right every day when I'm doing this
job I'm figuring out how can I make a
positive difference for all of you and I
knew that the protocol was the thing
that was making the biggest difference
uh the biggest problem and that's why we
needed to put the most effort in I'm
really pleased that we're able to
achieve that yesterday and I believe
hand on heart
that it provides a basis for all the
parties all the communities here to look
at it to look at the detail consider it
and they will see that it is a big step
forward that it does address the
concerns that people have and I hope
will allow them to come together put all
the division and arguments of the past
behind us come together and move forward
together and start to look forward to a
brighter future for Northern Ireland
that's what I think is now possible and
that's what I'd love to talk to you all
about and take your questions so thank
you for having me over to you
okay who's gonna kick it off right yes
lovely thank you good morning I wonder
Jazz you've talked an awful lot about
the benefits of the agreement in regards
to UK trade where obviously an
all-ireland business are there any
implications from that point of view
that we need to consider
no and that that's a really important
point and it's about balance
and we have to recognize that there's a
balance to be struck because it's really
important to me and to many of you that
in all ways shape and form that Northern
Ireland is fully part of the United
Kingdom we are one country and it can't
feel different it can't be different and
that's why we had some work to do to
correct some of those things but at the
same time we've got to recognize that
for businesses like the one we're in
having access
to that EU Market ensuring that there's
no border north south on the island of
Ireland is really important it's really
important for Northern Ireland's
prosperity for jobs
for opportunity and that's the balance
that we needed to strike and I'm really
pleased that we protected that balance
because that's something that I heard
loud and clear that as much as we wanted
to fix all the problems
we also couldn't lose the thing that
people valued and that's that's not been
easy it's been hard work but we have
protected that balance and that's why I
believe this is the right agreement for
Northern Ireland so businesses like
yours will continue to trade freely
Source freely on the island of Ireland
whilst having much easier access and
flow between Great Britain and Northern
Ireland and in all senses for identity
everyone feeling they're part of one
country that is what we've been able to
achieve but your right to highlight that
we need to think about that as well and
we have protected it for yours and every
other business that wanted it
right who's next
yes
thank you and given the climate crisis
in recent food shortages is it time for
the UK to reconsider its physician in
the single Market to ensure a
sustainable food supply in line with our
European neighbors and reduce food air
miles
right so the question everyone heard
about climate change and food
sustainability so look we obviously
climate change is one of the big things
that we're trying to tackle just a few
weeks ago I actually changed how
government works and we created a brand
new department for energy security and
Net Zero because I think it's that
important and I think we should have a
dedicated government Department that's
run by a brilliant guy called Grant
shaps who is going to focus on this
because those two things go hand in hand
if we want to continue reducing our
emissions we've got to find new forms of
cleaner renewable energy but we also
want them to be secure because we've all
seen what's happened over the past year
as Russia has invaded Ukraine and the
impact that's had on Energy prices we
never want to be in that situation ever
again so finding forms of renewable
energy here at home is really important
improving our energy security is vital
so that's what that Department's going
to do reduce our carbon emissions
improve our energy security but you
mentioned food that's really important
too I'm I come from uh oh I represent an
area in England in North Yorkshire my
neighbor is a Dairy Farmer very rural
agricultural part of the world much like
Northern Ireland's economy
disproportionately agricultural compared
to other parts of the UK and that's
really special and our Farmers want to
do that they want to increase the amount
of food that we produce here at home to
reduce those food Air Miles as you said
and I'm completely supportive of that
and one of the benefits of leaving the
EU is we can redesign all our
agricultural schemes I can see some
nodding from our farming representatives
in the audience and that's what we've
done because we can make sure that our
farming schemes really work for British
Farmers it supports the things that we
want them to do and importantly improves
our food security and does that in an
environmentally sustainable way and
that's the journey that we're on there
are opportunities for us to grow far
more here at home and I think with the
investment we're putting in that's what
we're going to do great for our Farmers
great for our food security but as you
said also great for the climate because
we're reducing those food air miles at
the same time
right who's next yes sir
the third topic
um
one in four children in Northern Ireland
are in Cherry poverty
what can the government do more to help
these children and families living in
poverty and going hungry
I mean I'm you know like like me I'm
sure many parents had right I have two
young girls they're nine and ten right
and it's actually to think of children
being in poverty is heartbreaking right
I can't yeah it's hard to imagine and
and you're right far too many children
are in poverty and we should be doing
everything we can to reduce that
now the best way the best way for us to
do that is to ensure that their parents
are in work so the absolute best way if
you look at if you look at the
statistics and you look at what happened
you are something like four or five
times less likely to be in poverty as a
child if your parents are in work it's
that striking it's that powerful and
we've done a really good job of that
over the last several years the number
of children growing up in families where
nobody works is down by almost a million
so it's almost 750 000 fewer children
growing up in a situation like that
which is brilliant and that's why there
are hundreds of thousands of fewer
children now in poverty today than there
were several years ago which is
something that we can celebrate but of
course we've got to do more so we've got
to make sure that we keep their parents
in work support them into work that's
why as we talked about Investments here
that's real right it's not just about
business it's not about the economy it's
about providing people with jobs and
jobs mean that people don't grow up in
poverty their kids don't grow up in
poverty and that's why getting this
framework right is so important because
it's about creating those jobs because
ultimately that will benefit all those
children and there's lots of other
things that we can do as well as many of
you know we provide free School meals
for children who desperately need it we
have other ways to support their parents
as well particularly with child care
costs and something that people don't
always know that if you're on Universal
Credit
and you want to work which is a good
thing and we want you to what we do now
is we reimburse 85 percent of all the
child care costs if you're someone who
is moving off benefits and into work
and you're worried about childcare costs
what happens is 85 percent of the cost
of that child care you can get
reimbursed to support you into work and
that's going to be good for you good for
your family and that's one of the things
that we can do to help it but you're
absolutely right we've got to keep going
but we've absolutely got to keep going
and I can tell you that we will
yes sir and then miss
thank you thank you with the UK
corporation tax rate set to increase to
25 from April this year at which point
it'll be double the rate in the Republic
of Ireland how can we ensure that
Northern Ireland still seeing as a an
attractive location for foreign direct
investment versus the Republic of
Ireland yeah brilliant right it's a
question everyone here about corporation
tax I did say to the business guys
earlier I'm not Chancellor anymore so I
knew I knew it was going to come anyway
um no look it's a really important
question right so you know why is it
it's going up it's going up for all the
reasons that I talked about a lot over
the summer and I talked about as
Chancellor that you know we're borrowing
an enormous amount of money that's not
good it's not good for the country we've
got to get the borrowing down we've got
to do that in a responsible way and
that's going to help us do it and if you
get that stuff wrong you saw what
happened last year we've already got
inflation higher than it is we've
already got interest rates higher than
we'd like them all of that just gets
worse and that's why we've got to get
our borrowing back down I it might sound
boring but I tell you it is deeply
important because if we care about those
kids that we don't want to grow up in
poverty we're not doing their many
favors if we're just putting a lot of
stuff on the country's credit card and
telling them to pick up the tab because
that is a Surefire way for them not to
have
um a happy and prosperous life so that's
why we've got to do it but look this is
why you don't need to worry about it
at 25 it will still be the lowest rate
out of all the large economies that we
compete with around the world right it
also only applies to the biggest 10 of
companies so the vast majority of
companies and obviously not Coca-Cola
that's different but the vast majority
of small businesses in Northern Ireland
won't see any change they'll continue to
pay the low rate that they're already
paying and the last thing to say is you
know what I want to see businesses doing
is investing more right so what I want
to see is businesses making money that's
good it's important that they do but
it's important that they invest that
money
and that's how we create jobs that's how
we drive our productivity just like Mars
is doing Coca-Cola is doing here
investing in new lines creating new jobs
so what we want to do is cut taxes on
the investment and that's what we're
doing so if you're a small or
medium-sized business if you want to
invest back in your company if you want
to invest in expanding your business
putting a new shop in expanding your
Warehouse whatever it is we have an
incredibly generous tax break for you
where you can write off all of that
investment against your taxes which is
quite generous doesn't exist anywhere
else in the world it has a very
technical name called the annual
investment allowance there's someone
here from KPMG or there was earlier so
they can explain it to everybody
afterwards but that's what we're going
to do and that's what we'd like to try
and do more of over time when the
circumstances allow now the chancellor
is the one in charge of that now but
he's very keen to drive growth to drive
investment and that's one way for us to
think about doing it I think the other
thing to say is because you talked about
Northern Ireland
that is the prize that is on offer
because if we get this right if we get
this framework implemented if we get the
executive back up and running here
Northern Ireland is in the unbelievably
special position unique position in the
entire world European continent in
having privileged access
not just to the UK Home Market which is
enormous fifth biggest in the world but
also the European Union single Market
nobody else has that
no one
only you guys only here
and that is the prize I can tell you
when I go around the world and talk to
businesses they that you know they know
that they're like that's interesting if
you guys get this sorted then we want to
invest in Northern Ireland because
nowhere else does that exist that's like
the world's most exciting economic zone
and one of the things that is top of
Secretary of State's in tray
once we get an executive up and running
here is to work with companies not just
in the UK but around the world to figure
out how do we get them to come and
invest in new things to take advantage
of Northern Ireland's very special
position and they are queuing up to do
so particularly from the US actually
they keep talking I say when are you
going to get this thing sorted because
we've got all these ideas we've got
investment that we want to bring just
like Mars is doing with Coca-Cola that's
what we need more of and that is the
prize and that is the potential that
we're going to realize
because remember the Republic of Ireland
doesn't have that right that is the
special thing that only is in Northern
Ireland not just the access to the EU
but the access to the UK Market it's
it's really important and very powerful
for companies right there was a yes miss
you yeah perfect
good morning
um one of the big challenges that North
are leave in Northern Ireland to seek
education and work elsewhere be it in
the UK or further afield what can
businesses and government do to attract
and retain young Talent within the
country
yeah does everyone hear that it's about
people having to wanting to leave
Northern Ireland so I don't want that to
happen right I say the same thing when
I'm at home in North Yorkshire right
what people say what does leveling up
mean to you what does leveling up mean
to me I tell you what it means it's
about opportunity it's about making sure
that everybody every young person
wherever they are growing up in our
country can fulfill all their dreams all
their Ambitions so they don't have to
leave now if they want to that's all
good and well fine but they shouldn't
have to that's what leveling up means to
me it's about spreading opportunity and
that's what we need to do and it's about
investment of course it is in
communities making sure that people
they're nice places to live that we're
investing in the infrastructure but it's
it's ultimately about skills and
education and jobs right that those are
the crystal well those are the things
that if we get right I think we can do
what you want to do and it's about
making sure that that young person feels
well I can get the world-class skills
that I need the education that I need
here at home
and then I'm going to get the job that I
want to do right and that is a mix of
things right to make sure our
apprenticeships are amazing that our
universities are amazing that our
schools are amazing and then that we've
got an environment where our businesses
are investing and creating those jobs in
all sorts of Industries and that's the
future for Northern Ireland I mean you
guys know it right there are World
leading Industries here
right not just the business that we're
standing in but in life sciences in
Pharmaceuticals and financial services
in cyber and advanced manufacturing I
could go on and on and on these aren't
just things that are good for the UK in
Northern Ireland these are things that
are good globally that's how high
quality what we've got here is so we
just need to build on those strengths
and make sure that if you're a young
person growing up in Northern Ireland
you know that you've got a world-class
education for you here at home and that
you've got an amazing job waiting for
you to go to and if we can get that
right then we're going to fix it but it
would be nice if some of you also come
over to Great Britain every so often not
least because half my office some of
them are here are all from Northern
Ireland and then I have no one left
working with me if you all stayed here
but but we need to get it right all
right who's next yes sir at Mac
good morning prime minister good morning
you're very welcome to knock more Hill
uh prime minister my 14 year old son is
a member of the Northern Ireland youth
assembly it's a body which was
established here to help young people
influence the work of Stormwind
especially in relation to those issues
that most the fact they am
how can we better demonstrate that the
young people in our society the politics
is a Force for good as opposed to
something that just divides us
well thank you for the welcome what a
great question and I pay tribute to your
son I guess the first question to to ask
him is his assembly is his assembly
sitting right now
Yes Prime Minister his assembly has
continued to sit there we go well you
know what that that's the example right
there right that is the example right
and that's what we need to see we need
to see people getting around a table we
need to see people engaging with the
detail of what we announced yesterday
and seeing that it does provide a way to
move forward because we've got to put
the division and the arguments of the
past behind us we've got to right if we
want to build a better future we want
young people not to have to leave to
fulfill all their dreams if we want to
make sure our kids grow up and in great
circumstances not in poverty then we
need a function in government here
and that's what you need that's what you
deserve and that's what I believe we've
created the conditions to now make
possible and that's the best example
though that your son and everyone who's
sitting in that assembly with him is
doing they're actually talking they're
actually talking they're getting around
a table they're discussing things
they're making a difference now unless
people are actually there doing that we
can't right and you guys know better
than me all the challenges that are
building up as a result of there not
being a government here and that's not
good enough right we all want to see
that fixed and that's why I really hope
that everyone here will give the
framework the time the consideration
that it deserves and see a way a way
forward because the events that I talk
about right at the beginning remind us
of the past they remind us of that
division no one wants to go back to that
we want to move forward together we want
to build a better future and I think
with this framework we've created the
conditions of that to be possible and I
really hope I know you I can see you
Noddy I know that that's what you will
want to and your son is setting an
amazing example and I hope everyone else
follows him and his colleagues friends
right how are we doing yes
Miss
good morning and the question's a bit
linked to the last one so mlas are
elected to do your job and they're paid
to do a job and they're not doing that
job and at a time when course of living
pressures are an all-time high and
taxpayers we're paying those salaries
when is enough enough
yeah that's a that's a really good
question
[Laughter]
yeah so I was just going to say that we
haven't actually done something on the
salary thing
um which uh because you're right right
and it's a it's a totally reasonable
point right and and Chris has uh
explained that in the past but we have
done something on the side we cut the
salaries haven't we yeah about 27 so to
your point we have done some of that
um because we do want them to be sitting
we do want them to be doing their job
but look I also recognize that there was
a reason they weren't doing that
and there was validity to their concerns
all right I'm going to be completely
honest about that the concerns that
people had with the protocol
were valid right now look how we deal
with that is a separate question but the
fact that people had concerns about it I
think is reasonable lots of people had
concerns that balance of the Good Friday
agreement had been unsettled and it
needed correcting but we have now
corrected it the framework is a
fantastic agreement that delivers on all
the things people care about so now I
hope that they do
see it and see that and then can find a
way to come back together and that's
what Chris wants to see is what I want
to see is what all of you want to see
it's what you deserve and what we've
done though is Empower that assembly
even more with this new storm won't
break that I talked about I mean even
more incentive to get back in So for all
the people who said well we don't feel
like we've got enough sovereignty in
this situation that there's a democratic
deficit with this EU we've corrected it
we've put more power in the hands of
storm on in those very people
so you know but they need to get back in
they need to get back in so they can use
those Powers we've provided the means
now and I hope that with time and space
they will see that that's the right way
forward and I absolutely want to give
them the time and space and work with
them and answer their questions but what
you want to see is what I want to see
and I think we can now see a wave that
that can be possible again
right yes
good morning
I we've already addressed this morning
by poverty and children in Northern
Ireland and for our more vulnerable for
those who can't go out to work the
energy scheme was essential was it
successful and is there any more help
coming for the people of Northern
Ireland yes
um gosh this has been the biggest
challenge over the last year that
everyone has been grappling with yep
protocol issues aside is the cost of
living right you guys there like for a
year every time you open up a bill you
see an email you're like oh my gosh
where did that come from right and it's
got worse and worse and worse right and
that's why
that's why my first promise that I made
this year when I as prime minister I saw
a maid of speech which hopefully some of
you at least saw some of but I made five
promises to the public the first one was
to halve inflation
because that is the thing that is
driving up everyone's bills particularly
with energy and that's why the question
right at the beginning we've got brand
new department for energy security now
because we've got to have cheaper forms
of energy here at home that's the best
long-term way to deal with the problem
but in the short term we do have to help
and that's why this year we've provided
an extraordinary amount of help billions
and billions of pounds you know about
the 600 pounds that's gone to all
households here and we've got more
support for the most vulnerable
households that is not ending we are
going to carry on supporting people over
this coming Financial year as well so
the most vulnerable are going to get
hundreds and hundreds of pounds again
through the welfare system pensioners
are going to get extra help those who
are disabled are going to get extra help
I announced lots of that as Chancellor
and the new chancellor has continued
that for another year and on top of that
the government is still continuing to
cap energy bills that's what the energy
prize guarantee is it means that
whatever happens the government is just
going to step in and cap the maximum
that anyone will pay so that is a really
big statement of support to everybody
and on top of that we've got extra
support for the most vulnerable because
it's right that we always have them in
our mind as well and then long term with
our new Department with brilliant Grand
chaps we're going to have more offshore
wind more renewable energy which is
going to bring bills down and make us
more secure at home but don't worry we
are not going to let anyone get left
behind between now and then and the good
news is that the plan is working
inflation looks like touchwood the worst
of it is behind us for on the downward
track and that's why when it come no
one's asked about public sector pay
which I'm amazed about so far and
Strikes but that's why you know we've
had to be disciplined because the worst
thing I can do is not deliver on that
pledge to halve inflation
because it means you're still going to
be dealing with bills going up in a
year's time and that's no good we've got
to just it's going to be tougher a
little bit but we will get through it
trust me we will if we stick to the plan
the plan is working inflation is coming
down by the end of the year it's going
to look and feel so much better but we
just got to stick to the plan and that's
what we're going to do and we're going
to deliver for you and everyone else
sorry
thank you for that commitment thank you
right okay I think we're almost running
out of time I'm getting waved out we'll
take a couple more yes yes
good morning prime minister
slightly in terms of
no one here wants to see a return to
violence
um having grown up at the teal end of
the troubles myself I certainly don't
want it for our young people
unfortunately the ni protocol has been
extremely divisive of communities here
how confident are you that this new deal
will help heal those divisions
great question do you want to should I
take your question as well sir you have
one and then I'll do them both together
before we wrap up
um there's a huge opportunity to improve
the electric vehicle infrastructure
currently in Northern Ireland with the
lowest charge points per 100 000 people
in the UK and we have about 35 of the UK
average so how can the government help
increase that one forward right okay I
didn't know that so thank you for
letting me know the question was about
electric vehicle charge points so we're
not doing as well as we should here well
let me go and take that away and have a
look at it
right well yeah actually of Christopher
replied to me so because I was going to
say a lot of what we're doing probably
relies on there being a functioning
government here because we are doing
quite a lot actually to support the
rollout of electric vehicle charging
infrastructure and the other the stats
that I saw recently actually show that
we're doing really well but that's
probably on a UK wide basis and we need
to do a better job here well that's an
important reminder to us about why we
need a functioning government here
because we've got various subsidy
schemes we've provided money for local
councils so we've got lots going on
actually and there's this new body
called the UK infrastructure bank that I
set up which is a kind of government
bank that partners with private
companies and they're rolling out
charging infrastructure as well we've
got a fund so there's lots going on
obviously it's not working here I will
take it away with Chris but the main
thing is we need a functioning
government here to get on and solve
things like that actually and because I
think last year called one in five cars
I think almost electric right I think
we're almost so we're really on an
upward trajectory here so we've got to
make sure that the infrastructure is
there for us and let me finish on your
question actually which is
brilliant question to end on
and you know you know what I um so I
went to University in 1998.
and so just
Belfast Good Friday agreement that's
when I became an adult so I've grown up
as an adult under that agreement for the
past quarter of a century I mean my
roommate at University hope he doesn't
mind me saying but my roommate at
University was from Oma and I didn't you
know I came from Southampton I didn't
particularly know anyone very well from
Northern Ireland he actually as it
turned out didn't really know any Indian
people either and we spent a lot of time
getting to know each other and learning
about each other's backgrounds and it
was I mean eye-opening to me how he had
grown up right what he had grown up
having to deal with and and live with
and so low I
I'm passionately committed to making
sure that the Good Friday agreement
works because it has brought peace and
stability to Northern Ireland and that
is so precious and we're reminded of how
precious it was just this past week and
the protocol disrupted that balance
because the Belfast Good Friday
agreement if it's about anything is
about respecting that balance it's about
respecting the aspirations and
identities of all communities in
Northern Ireland so we can move Beyond
division put it behind us and move
forward together and it did that very
well but the protocol disrupted it which
is why it needed resolving that's why
I've spent so much time personal
attention and Care on this issue and
it's why I passionately believe
that yesterday the Windsor framework
delivers and removing the source of that
division restores balance it means that
things can flow freely around the UK
internal Market as they should because
we are one country and that should be
easy it means that we've protected
Northern Ireland's place in the union so
that if you're living in Northern
Ireland it looks feels and is the same
as if you're anywhere else in the
country and you have the same benefits
and crucially it restores sovereignty to
the people and institutions of Northern
Ireland so you are in control of your
destiny because that is what is right it
is a major breakthrough it is an
enormously positive step forward and now
I hope as I said everyone can take time
to study it see that and then we can
move forward together put the Division
behind us get an executive back up and
running and build a far brighter future
for everyone in Northern Ireland we're
going to do that together and I think
it's going to be incredibly positive so
thank you very much for having me
okay